what do you want to know I'll tell you
given you what would you get this time
around of directing is there anything
different or didn't you learned or
what's your approach uh it was it was a
bit of a an increased challenge because
I was while we're coming off hiatus so
it's like the first thing getting back
into it now I'm directing but I'm also
having to introduce essentially a new
character which is you know demonic
version of Dean and it's I find it
difficult I was saying another table
over there I'm like I don't know how you
know Ben Affleck or Ben Stiller or you
know even going back like Mel Gibson
with Braveheart or Dances with Wolves
and come across terms like I'd love to
ask them like how do you guys do it
because I find it very difficult to take
the directors hat off and put the actors
hat on and then vice versa so and then
also trying to introduce a new character
at the same time it was it was a head
spin hopefully hopefully it worked out
awfully you guys like it but you know
we'll see I actually go into editing on
Tuesday to to cut to give them my cut so
nervous
well there's certainly a benefit to
living with the character living on the
skin of the character or so long as you
have done but what is the largest
challenge
of living with a character for that long
it'll be having to let him go eventually
I think I think it's a good question he
said he said living with a character for
so long what's the biggest challenge of
living with that character and I said
it'll probably be letting him go yeah
yeah absolutely that's gonna be really
difficult
I want him without but I think one of
them I think the in my opinion the
biggest challenge of living with
character is solved by frankly by the
show Supernatural because usually a
character becomes stagnant or stale and
boring but we do so many crazy wild
things and we're able to because the
fans forgive us and they stay with us
and supernatural is such a show that you
can do anything you can become a demon
you can become an angel you can go
soulless and you get to explore all
these new different facets it's not like
we're playing guys who are in high
school and now there's really there's
like a now there's a romance with this
person now is really fun what's next
like what's going to happen
it's just crazy bizarre show we can
literally go anywhere and we almost have
so that's the that's the most different
part of currently living with characters
make sure it has a ghost ale but it also
each other it'll bounce off of - yeah I
mean it's you know there's it's just
kind of like it you know the equalizer
you know it's like I've got I've got
Dean and I've got him in my head and
I've got all this stuff but then as soon
as they all cut it's like he and I kind
of bring each other right back out of it
number you know
Jarrid again so it's it's there's
there's a nice balance that comes with
having somebody that you work with so
close you know as opposed to you know
somebody like Stephen Amell or from like
Tom Welling who's really kind of solo
flying solo
you know we effectively he tells Stephen
all the time is like too bad it's just
you because you know how we had is
you're having a partner in crime is
really the way to go
you